it's getting ever harder for number ten
to sweep the opposition to the Prime
Minister's top advisor away but still
they try here
police helping Dominic Cummings but with
Durham police opening a formal
investigation into him a minister
resigning over his contact and more than
30 Tory MPs calling publicly for his
sacking the path ahead doesn't look
straightforward and then what
at first glance appeared to be a
rewriting of government policy on the
who will the government review all
penalty fines imposed on families
traveling for childcare purposes during
lockdown we do understand the impact and
the need for making sure that children
get adequate childcare that is one of
the significant concerns that we've had
all the way through this and so I think
especially coming from a man of the
cloth I think that is a perfectly
reasonable to take away that question I
have to talk to my Treasury colleagues
before I can answer it in full minutes
later the suggestion of a review was
junked illustrating a government
struggling with what's happening
ministers headline is that there's still
nothing to see here
mr. Cummings House set out all of the
details in quite extensive detail
yesterday and then invited questions on
it my view is that what he did was
within the guidelines the most important
thing is that we can we can get on and
deal with the other issues but Boris
Johnson's own MPs didn't want to get on
with other issues from every wing and
most intakes including one-time holders
of high office the Tory leader in
Scotland possibly the biggest beast of
all to call for Dominic Cummings
resignation
and a minister quit someone regarded as
a loyalist until today in his
resignation statement Douglas Ross said
he couldn't after this episode tell his
constituents they were all wrong and a
senior adviser to the government was
right
Dominic Cummings made his name in that
building over there running the main
brexit campaign vote leave in the EU
referendum now when he went into Downing
Street he brought with him several of
the closest aides from that period
now MPs over here are trying their
hardest to get Dominic Cummings out of
number 10 but it's the reason that Boris
Johnson is reluctant because he worries
he might get three or four vote leavers
resigning for the price of one the
public want Dominic Cummings out with a
YouGov poll today showing 59% want him
to resign yes I think he should
apologize and also resign he he made out
this he build a story to fit the
allegation people are coming out look
down themselves I think you should
apologize that I think you should get
the sack I do think you should apologize
and get the feeling he's not as open as
he should be
MPs get their first chance to ask Boris
Johnson about Dominic Cummings tomorrow
how on earth has an unelected advisor
ended up seeming so vital Sam Cote Sky
News